security forces in Northern Kosovo have
surrounded at least 30 gunmen hours
after a police officer was shot dead
authorities have killed three of the
attackers and arrested one
kosovo's prime minister says the group
is holed up in a monastery in the
village of banshka and urged them to
surrender he has accused Serbia of
backing what he called a terrorist
attack
I ask all these individuals to surrender
to the security authorities because we
want the rule of law peace and security
to Reign for all citizens without any
distinction knowing that this is not a
fight with armed civilians but with
people who are heavily armed and pose a
great danger not only to the
Constitutional order and law in Kosovo
but also to the safe day of all citizens
the unrest began earlier on Sunday after
a heavily armed men blocked a bridge in
banshka and fired on arriving police
units the attack threatens to derail a
EU facilitated negotiations to normalize
relations between Kosovo and Serbia
has more from kosovo's capital bristina
the attack took place when the Border
Police Patrol after midnight noticed two
trucks without license plates blocking
the bridge in one of the villages in
north of Kosovo where ethnic serbs are
in majority three police units were
called in to assist with the situation
and upon their arrival a group of masked
men opened the fire at the police
the attackers threw hand grenades and a
handheld rocket launcher was also used
according to the police during the
attack a police officer was killed and
another one was wounded police presence
in the north of Kosovo has been
increasing after the attack American
soldiers serving under a nato-led
international peacekeeping forces here
in Kosovo also at the site where the
attack took place however gunshots were
heard even this morning tensions have
run high in Kosovo after clashes in may
even more than 90 NATO or peacekeeping
soldiers and some 50 ethnic serbs
protesters were injured in the north EU
sponsored talks on normalizing relations
between Kosovo and Serbia two former
wartime foes stalled last week after
failing to agree on the implementation
plan to normalize relations